I'll ask joss whedon lots of questions a
party's aliens where they come from and
what do they look like what do they look
yeah and what's the deal that's been
made so Loki's been given this sceptre
by whom and for what purpose and I think
I was one of the first people to ask him
that question and he said vanos so I go
who
tell me about him and and then you know
Kevin is on set and they tell me about
how nice and I go ah so that so so
there's a thing in the tesseract and
there's one in the scepter okay but I
don't know at this point that you know
Ultron is coming around and that they're
gonna be new characters based on what's
inside Loki's scepter I mean the thing
is after the dark world I went off on a
sabbatical and I wasn't in the Marvel
Universe for a while and I went to watch
all the new films as they came out and
they was always talking about Loki's
scepter and I was like still in there
somewhere
the thing is that he is redeemed and I
found it very touching because Loki as a
character has been so broken for so long
and I think the center of him has been
very fragile and very isolated after
those traumatic events in the first film
when he finds out he was adopted but not
only Weig he was adopted that his
parents or his father had left him to
die so he has internalized that shame of
being abandoned and being alone and and
in all of that shame is turned into
something harder and angrier which is
why he becomes the villain he becomes he
becomes down to earth he tries to
subjugate it it becomes a villain in
every sense of the word he's motivated
by hatred and anger and then he loses
his mother and he's still kind of
oneself away in that way and it's only
the event it's only losing his father
who calls him one of his sons Odeon
includes him says are my sons at the
beginning of Ragnarok and the chaos of
another sibling it ain't no hello
turning up and sullen fallen Loki after
join forces and
and for really gets through to Loki in
that way and so to have it all come full
circle and for Loki to call himself an
odin son to really identify with that to
identify with the strength of his
father's love before saving his brother
I found really touching everybody as
Charlie I got a lot of requests to do a
video about why Marvel just made a huge
retcon to Loki's character in the MCU
going all the way back to the first
Avengers film in advance of Avengers
endgame and a lot of it has to do with
bringing Loki back in what they're gonna
be doing with the character in this
Disney Plus streaming TV show so we'll
break it down we're doing a new round of
that imax ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite Loki moment on the
video so Tom Hiddleston beautifully
talks about his character in where a lot
of his misdirected rage comes from and
why he does a lot of the things he does
through the film's that we've seen so
far he narrates most of Loki's backstory
through all the films but the really
important part is that you know he sort
of descends to this really awful place
at the end of the first Thor film and
disappears into the wormhole and winds
up on sanctuary in Thanos domain so you
just have to remember where Loki is
before the events of the first Avengers
film and why he is the way he is during
that film it completely recontextualizes
the character now the reason why this is
important is because there's going to be
a lot of original Avengers movie stuff
happening during Avengers endgame
through whatever theory that you want to
endorse whether it's the be ar effing
technology or whether it's something
crazier like alternate dimensions
alternate realities or even full-blown
time travel the Loki that we see in
Avengers endgame or at least one of the
Loki's that we see we know will be from
the events of that first Avengers film
I've already done a video about the
deleted scenes and how they basically
confirmed that the Loki that we knew
this whole time died during Avengers
infinity war trying to defend Thor in
that last bit gambit even though he kind
of did it in a weird way with the wrong
hand that he doesn't normally use and it
raises a lot of other questions
Loki's new backstory is is that when he
disappeared in the wormhole and
initially met Thanos Thanos recognized
what happened with his family
Thanos has spies all over the universe
so he knows about
most of the high-profile stuff that's
going on so he plays into the events of
what happened between Loki and his
family between him and Thor during the
events of that first Thor film
Loki's feeling like an outsider he feels
completely alone
Santos swoops in and manipulates him
into leading his charge to earth to try
and get their hands on the tesseract so
they can get one of the other Infinity
stones so already a lot of Loki's
actions as a villain at least in the
early phase one movies is largely due to
the influence of Thanos not so much that
he had any desire to be a villain or to
kill Thor or any of his other family
members or his former friends the way
that Tom Hiddleston talks about it now
but the big point of retcon that Marvel
just introduced and this is actually a
really big deal they said that just as
Loki was using the mine stone to
mind-control people like Hawkeye during
that movie Thanos when he was teaching
Loki how to use the sceptre was also
using the mine stone to mind-control
Loki himself so you have Thanos
manipulating Loki on a bunch of
different levels not just trying to play
into his idea of hatred and desire for
revenge but also slipping in some mind
control to make sure that he hates his
brother and wants to do all these things
the actual quote reads offering the god
of mischief dominion over his brother's
favorite realm of Earth Thanos requested
the tesseract in return gifted with a
scepter that acted as a mind-control
device Loki would be able to influence
others unbeknownst to him the scepter
was also influencing him feeling his
hatred over his brother Thor in the
inhabitants of Earth I think it's a
beautiful addition to his back story
because Loki himself has treated as kind
of a pawn and a lot of the things he
does it makes it seem like he's not
quite in control of his destiny which is
the way he sort of starts out like he
doesn't feel like he's gained control so
he lashes out and tries to take over
Asgard while Thor's away but in the
grand scheme of things they wanted to
redeem the character through his actions
in thor ragnarok or at least by the time
we've gotten around to Thor Ragnarok and
in Infinity Ward definitively like this
is my last act of heroism to try and
save my brother and give my life for him
so you ask why would they introduce that
detail right as we're starting to get
Avengers and gain trailers and as
they're starting to get ready to shoot
the actual Loki TV series which may or
may not end up premiering later this
year I think in the context of what's
happening during the events of Avengers
endgame it's just to make his character
feel a little consistent with what's
happening during infinity war because
the Russos say that they do want people
to watch those movies back-to-back as if
you know it is two films although you
watch it in one sitting as if it's one
story divided into two big parts so that
you go from seeing the Loki that we've
seen in the last couple of movies who's
redeemed himself he's a good character
he's not a villain anymore he's a little
mischievous but he's not a villain you
get two Avengers endgame in that part of
Loki sort of seeps through in the scenes
that he does get now the only Loki
scenes that we know about during
avengers endgame right now are the stuff
that we've seen from behind the scenes
and that's when they're shooting the
events of the original Avengers film
with cap in his original Avengers
costume his old shield Iron Man walking
around with those special risk devices
on with ant-man so yes it is totally
possible that a Loki from beyond the
grave or from Valhalla could have some
sort of moment with Thor at the very end
of endgame but that's just speculation
I wouldn't expect to see anything like
that in any of the trailers in the way
that they're also probably not going to
put spider-man in any of the trailers
even though we know that he's coming
back but Marvel in making Loki look like
more of a pawn through the events of the
first Avengers film in all those early
films also makes it a little bit easier
for them to write him as the protagonist
in a relatively good well-meaning
character albeit mischievous during his
TV series so that it doesn't wind up
being eight episodes of Loki just
traveling around the universe being an
[ __ ] to everyone depending on what
time period that's set during and the
really interesting thing about that
retconning Loki is I don't think that
it's gonna stop there I think you know
in the next five or six years when we're
in phase four and we're moving into
phase five they'll continue to reveal
new details that'll recontextualize the
characters in the events of this first
era of Marvel films like you always hear
about really cool deleted scenes and
ideas that they had they completely
changed the way you see the films even
infinity wars probably a good example
that because it's such a big film with
so much stuff that had to be left on the
cutting room floor right now no joke the
Russos legit
they said that they're thinking about
doing a three-hour cut of avengers
endgame even though i don't think that
disney would ever let them actually do
that the biggest reason why you don't
see stuff like that happen in theaters
is just because it limits the amount of
time so they can show a movie during the
day which means the theater owners earn
less money in the earn less box office
that's why the longest Marvel films
you've seen so far infinity war Captain
America Civil War just like a little bit
over two and a half hours early
prediction because avengers endgame is
the final film in the first era of
Marvel films and they have to sort of
bookend all of these characters it's
maybe like a couple minutes longer than
those films but still below 2 hours and
40 minutes and it'll just be like 20 or
30 minutes of deleted scenes and bonus
features when they release the blu-ray
but we got a whole bunch of stuff coming
up there'll be plenty more Avengers
videos there's a new Captain Marvel
trailer that's going to be dropping next
week so of course I'll do a video for
that if there's any really big Marvel
video or big question that you want me
to do a video for leave it in the
comments below click here for that New
Avengers endgame teaser video and to
listen to Kevin Feige talk about what
he's doing with x-men characters this
year and click here for that new Captain
Marvel trailer video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]